brittany grinder locked up man
do you know the background of this story
are you familiar with it yeah okay do
you want to break it down a little bit
yeah so basically in so brittany griner
is a wnba player yeah she plays for a
wnba team in the united states and in
the offseason you go to russia play for
a wnba team there and that's where you
make a ton of money because the
oligarchs basically run the league
sponsor everything bread up all the
girls that play yeah i mean she was
making like a million dollars a year to
go play over there she's not making
close to that here i think the team she
was playing for is is in it katarina
berg or something like elkenberg or
something like that i don't know the
exact name but yeah basically she goes
over there she's been playing there
since 2015. so she's going she's gone
for the past seven years back and forth
to russia like she has roots in russia
like where she's like has her house
where she goes and stays the whole deal
yeah and then this time around she went
and like i there's no exact date early
feb i think it was like february 4th or
something like that early feb is what
i've heard so she goes early february
and she's in the airport going into
russia and as she's walking past like a
narcotics dog the dog sniffs what they
claim like narcotic material in her bag
they search her bag and they find
basically like hash oil or vape oil from
her it's a vape that has hash oil in it
allegedly yeah and then they say all
right yeah this is like a class one
narcotic blah blah russia you're trying
to bring narcotics into russia that's
like a huge crime five to ten years in
prison and basically she's locked up but
no one knew what had happened at the
time so it had been a month basically
and then new york times breaks the
article says you know brittany brown
grimer's been in prison for the last
month
keep this in mind here
this is a week before the russia ukraine
war
starts
so
when this story pops up i think it was
two days ago
everybody's going oh [ __ ] she was going
over there and they got they locked her
up and they're using this as some sort
of like tool for war right we're gonna
get a high-profile athlete from america
and keep them in prison this will put
pressure on america to either negotiate
with us or help us get what we want etc
um
i don't think that and now that we know
that it happened weeks ago
i don't think that this i think this was
coincidental i think brittany [ __ ] up
by having some hash oil in the vape they
arrest her at the airport and i think
that she's in
jail and i think before russia invades
ukraine they're probably doing a check
to see which americans and which
high-profile americans are in russia all
of a sudden britney gets flagged and
they're like ooh
thank you very much thank you very much
because please believe if you're a
high-profile athlete in russia and you
get caught with a little vape oil
you're let out yeah these oligarchs are
doing whatever the [ __ ] they want we
went to a strip club with hookers it was
right across the street from like the
court
in moscow there's no rules as long as
you have money and these oligarchs could
easily get her ass out without a
question
and but
a week let's say they find out two days
before they invade russia ukraine they
knew they were invading russia ukraine
for months yeah apparently and i can't
confirm this but the gg ping or whatever
the [ __ ] chinese guy he told him not
to do it until after the olympics yeah
so an invasion is planned for months
right right right you got to make sure
that you have a war chest built up
meaning you have enough money that you
could sustain any type of hits not only
to your army but to your economy right
like what these sanctions are doing for
us right now i think they saved up 650
billion dollars as a worchest right so
they knew what's going on
that gets flagged
and i don't know this for sure but 100 i
believe that they're keeping her ass
there
yeah as like a bargaining chip yes i
don't even know if it's a bargain chip
but just basically a way to like put a
little pressure on the us yeah like we
could keep your girls here simple as
that and then what do we do
she broke the rule
yeah i mean the rule yeah man
what do we do
do we go to war for a girl who broke the
rule going into another country i think
an a-list movie star would get locked up
for doing something like this and they
would not get let out and we wouldn't
have much leverage i don't think so like
i think for brittany grinder
it's weird because maybe she thought
like i won't get in any trouble i got
this oligarch back in me because i'm
trying to figure out what makes you so
bold as you take drugs internationally i
i honestly it could be an accident i
would 100 believe that it's like it was
a silly vape pen it was in one of her
bags she's got three different bags
she's gonna [ __ ] amsterdam for a week
doesn't he remember like yeah i mean she
was flying new york to
from yeah it was new york to moscow but
like i this is my assumption i don't
think she's going i'm gonna sneak this
by and she probably knows how strict
things are in russia granted she's
backed by this oligarch who can get her
out of any trouble that being said let's
not ruffle feathers also she's aware
way more aware than most people of the
tensions between russia and ukraine
apparently they were all told this stuff
people in the ukraine were told get the
[ __ ] out weeks before
so she chose to go back
knowing full well what was going on
between russia and the ukraine and that
war was going to probably happen within
ukraine so it's not going to hurt her in
russia but still that that is her bread
and butter that's where she makes all
the money that's where you make the
money i understand you're going back i
also i don't i i feel sorry for her i
also think there is a part of you that's
like yo you know where you're going you
know what the stakes are
you got to be pretty [ __ ] careful yo
yeah i don't think you
have room to say
and it's not saying i don't feel bad for
but you don't have room to say ah i just
packed the normal bag that i packed you
got to look through your [ __ ] pretty
thoroughly if you know you're going to
russia at a time like this and you were
warned about it 100
but i do un i do also go like
have i really looked into my backpack
you know what i mean i got a bunch of
pockets in my backpack i don't really
know what the [ __ ] is in there it's
possible that there's a little vape pen
or there's some [ __ ] cbd oils
honestly domestic i i i completely
understand how that and i don't smoke
weed but like yeah you're going from
[ __ ] here to colorado or i mean it's
illegal there but you know what i'm
saying like what if she's not packing
her bag
this is a millionaire nba wnba player
she's got all these different things
like true her wife could be packing her
back yeah and her wife could have left
it in there from the last time they
would did a trip together this could be
completely accidental i don't think she
was like knowingly trying to break the
law thinking oh they're not going to do
anything to me on brittany griner i
think
she's
got into russia plenty of times with it
yeah so it's like she's like oh i'm good
yeah but
i get taken care of now if somebody else
packed their bag that's different but if
you've been warned you know you're going
you're making a choice to go at a pretty
crazy time you have to know this isn't
any this isn't just every other time
i've gone yes this is a different thing
this is almost like uh the nba players
in the bubble is like oh you can't get
anything in and out in and out
the big players got whatever the [ __ ]
they needed
so she's looking she's probably going
there it's like ah i'll be all right
like i have an oligarch
owns my team that is i'll be good no
this is this is what what i was saying
is is really interesting
when you see how malleable the law is
yeah right for this oligarch or for the
team that you're playing with when you
see how malleable the rules are and they
are malleable in these countries right
when i say these countries i mean the
countries where if you have money [ __ ]
just goes your way yeah right you start
to think
that you are the oligarch
you are above the rules you she didn't
she probably and i don't even blame her
for this didn't realize
how distant she was from that oligarch
she is an american which is an enemy of
the state that's the thing you got to be
aware of the fact that you're not
like you're not an oligarch not only not
an oligarch you're an american
like that's a different [ __ ] thing
how much how much is brittany griner or
the average american really reading up
about like russia ukraine if you're
living there you should be aware
if if some if she was just visiting and
it's in her bag cool i can understand
and i'm not saying i don't feel bad you
there's a lot of validity to what you're
saying i also think there's validity to
you gotta be [ __ ] careful though
what can we do for you i went to the
ukraine while they were at war with
russia for a party weekend
you weren't on your best behavior no i
found a girl in a nightclub yeah and
then i paid for a hooker by going to
five different atms got locked up we
would i would do everything i could
personally to get you out or whatever
but like what the [ __ ] is shell thinking
no i mean every one of us would be like
privately what the [ __ ] was this guy
thinking fam 100 i guess what i'm trying
to say and you have every right to say
that like i put myself in that situation
i guess what i'm saying is i can see how
it's easy to be negligent yes and it's
easy like i didn't even research how
close kiev was to crimea and where the
[ __ ] was going down i didn't even look
into it
and we went that year i only went you
were like that's the only spot where my
dates line up my mom says yeah dress
warm i'm like me english that's it
i got a message from expedia this is an
active war zone what
what why did you tell me that before i
[ __ ] bought the ticket they let me
buy the ticket i get a message
afterwards yeah by the way don't by the
way yeah they go by this is an active
war zone do you also need a rental car
a sheltie looked at his phone is like
it's not an act of war zone yeah
that probably won't happen
yeah by the way also she should know a
lot of these russian rules i mean she's
a lesbian and russia isn't the
friendliest to
i mean they're paying these wnba players
a lot of money who says that they're not
friendly towards this first but then
afterwards you know what they were doing
for years oh yeah what was that song by
the two little light lesbians over there
i don't think she said all the things
she said
tattoo yeah yeah yeah yeah they were
firebra yeah whatever happened to them
with that i don't know wnba somewhere i
don't know
[Laughter]
okay so then what happens to brittany
griner
she's staying dog until sanctions are
like we're on the brink of world war
three we can't [ __ ] around with anybody
in another prison
i don't care who you are if it's brad
pitt hey you in that [ __ ] who
would we go get
any do you think it's any nba player
i mean lebron we're getting
do you think so yeah yeah it's not even
a question
we're getting lebron
hostile or like hey hey you take what
you want no i think there's going to be
like a conversation that's behind the
scenes
and where it's like we're going to need
lebron back yeah and then they're going
to go well you have two of our spies
and then we're going to go okay you can
get responses for the bronx yes yes he's
that important cultural figure it makes
america look so weak if we can't get
lebron james think about it you're young
so lebron is like jordan for your
generation imagine michael jordan was
locked up abroad
that's war fam i'm not gonna lie
people need to get killed
people need to get killed you can
possibly drop a nuke
for jordan
jordan there
oh no that's their shield
we're going to drop it somewhere away
the surrounding cities yeah
[Laughter]
on his own to be honest with you i don't
think he could get locked up yeah oh
yeah i think he'd just hop over them
[ __ ] jails game six versus